hallo leute hier sie teure marken und
willkommen zu einem neuen test video
heute habe ich mir die frage gestellt
merkt man wirklich den unterschied ob
ein wein zum beispiel acht euro gekostet
hat oder nur drei euro und da ich gerade
sehr viel zu hause sitze und ab und zu
mir mal ein glas wein könne nur reisen
von roten bekomme ich kopfschmerzen
wollte ich meinen horizont erweitern und
euren vielleicht auch und schaue mal ob
ich einen unterschied schmecke zwischen
den einzelnen sorten also ich glaube das
sind die rebsorten chardonnay seien
andere rebsorte als einen riesling und
ich wollte wissen merke ich den
unterschied zwischen neuses günstig das
ist die frage die wir uns heute stellen
und dafür habe ich jeweils ein glas und
es würde sagen lasst uns trinken des
videos ich würde sagen wir starten mit
unseren riesling kandidaten weil die
beiden schon ein wenig leiden mussten
timo wollte unbedingt mal ein glas wein
und ich auch und deswegen haben wir
wissen was davon getrunken auch unser
rechten seite haben wir den kloster
eberbach von 2018 riesling classic und
wir befinden uns bei dieser flasche bei
7 eur 99 seit neun jahrhunderten
bereitet die weine aus unserem weingut
genuss und freude muss ganz wenig muss
zehn weine probieren direkter vergleich
und auch unserer linken seite haben wir
den günstigen riesling kerner
halbtrocken aus dem jahr 2009 10 eine
literflasche also da ist sogar ein
bisschen mehr drin und preislich müssen
wir uns jeweils zwei euro
einzig das bedeutet mehr inhalt und
nicht mal die hälfte des preises optisch
würde ich dir jetzt gar nicht so richtig
auseinanderhalten können also der teure
sieht ein bisschen gelber aus der
günstige heller weißer aber jetzt muss
der geschmack überzeugen man den
günstigen okay ich versuche den rhein zu
beschreiben
sauer zitronig blumig und jetzt müssen
wir mal schauen mich der teure dagegen
um
der teure schmeckt auf jeden fall weiter
im mund ist nicht ganz so sehr ich in
dieser partie geht ein bisschen mehr ab
ich finde ich hier kommt dieses blumigen
bisschen mehr raus also ich würde schon
sagen dass mir der teure besser schmeckt
der schmeckt dagegen wirklich sauer
der hat irgendwie als ob da mehr
passieren würde keine ahnung wie bei
einem indischen gericht wurde so gerät
die viele gewürze schmeckt und da habe
ich das gefühl dass es bei dem teuren
auf jeden fall der fall ist trotzdem
würde ich jetzt nicht sagen dass der
abstimmt ist seit die studenten version
quasi von dem was die eltern trinken
aber der punkt geht dann also familie
aus geht der punkt an teuer
als nächstes bekämpfen sich zwei silvana
auf der rechten seite der teure silvana
saale und droht 2018 trockenfrucht von
willis vereinigung freyburg unstrut ein
fruchtig holunder und basilikum aromen
okay der teure silvaner kostet sechs
euro 49 und unser günstiger kandidat ist
der deutsche qualitätsweine silvaner
trocken aus dem jahr 2019 für einen
preis von 2 euro und 19
das ist ganz schön viel weniger dann
schenken wir mal wie dieses
basilikum getränk ein kleiner schuss und
einmalig günstige kandidat ein
vollmundiger silvaner mit harmonischer
säure sein buch erinnert an reife äpfel
aprikosen und zitrusfrüchte holunder und
basilikum dann ist natürlich jetzt
unterschiedlich die optik sieht der
teure ist wieder ein bisschen mehr geld
das klingt auf jeden fall machbar sie
die comcast oben wo jetzt kriege ich den
unterschied das riecht würziger das
blumige fruchtiger ich freue mich schon
auf die wein spezialisten die jetzt in
den kommentaren ihr ganzes wissen von
sich geben werden
ich bin schon sehr erfreut ist zu lesen
wir fangen mit dem günstigen an
also ich beschreibe meinen geschmack
sehr sauer
das einzige was ich schmecke ist sauer
ich würde sagen ja reife äpfel aprikosen
und zitrusfrüchte stimmt so habe ich ja
spannend auf den teuren silvaner könnte
noch seien aber war silikon finden
silvana ist so ein bisschen zu der wild
zu viel so ein bisschen wie die leute
auf einer party die ich nicht in ruhe
lassen wollen und dann immer noch was
sagen du da sagst ja ok ich muss zurück
zu meinen leuten und da silva kommt so
ja ich habe aber noch warte warte warte
da ist auch ein geschmack also ich hätte
erwartet dass man irgendwie gar keinen
unterschied schmeckt ich dachte so gut
irgendwelche weinkenner ja die werden
das jetzt anders finden besser
schlechter keine ahnung also beide waren
jetzt nicht der größte hit aber leider
hat die teure flasche wieder gewonnen
weil und das ist halt auch nur der
einzige grund der günstigen ist einfach
nur sauer gewesen unser nächster kommen
die dort im kino verlieren
das gefühl man erkennen die teuren und
die günstigen flaschen einfach schon
daran dass sie im hintergrund einfach so
eine schmähschrift verwenden unser
teurer kandidat ist der pinot grigio
kilo greco vom gardasee aus italien wo
der marke bartholdy das veronese gebiet
östlich des gardasees eignet sich
hervorragend für den anbau schmackhafter
fruchtiger qualitätsweine wir sind bei
der teuren flasche mit fünf euro 99
dabei und unser günstiger kandidat der
pinot grigio del wenn netze von der
marke lorenzer aus dem jahr 2018 der slk
dafür aber mehr als die hälfte günstiger
249 ich hab noch nie im kino getrunken
deswegen weiß ich nicht was mich
erwartet nun ihr könnt ihr mal in die
kommentare schreiben welcher euer
lieblings weißwein ist ok er fest die
seen exakt gleich aus kommen wir zum
geruchstest der teure wo also ich fast
gar nichts
sehr mild und der sich dafür umso mehr
umgeschlagen wieder beim günstigen
kandidaten
er hat eine leichte fußnote im abgang
obwohl ich muss mich muss man jetzt hier
neutral wenn ich diesen wein irgendwo
angeboten kriegen würde dann würde ich
sagen ja dort ist ein weißwein gewähren
wir mal den teuren pin aubry oder zu
ende gehen
er schmeckt machado ich sage euch gleich
welche marke welche sorte er schmeckt
nach einer krebs schmücken durch sein
elegantes und intensives
womit er sich besonders gut als aperitif
sowie als begleiter zu salaten an die
passende pizza pasta saucen
das ist in der krise ein der schmeckt
auch nach blume und so aber wenn man
einmal das lakritz geschmeckt hat kommt
man davon nicht mehr weg ich bin aber
auch nicht so geil welcher aber besser
lohnt sich der preis lohnt sich mehr
geld auszugeben bisher ich habe ich
gerade so widersprechende gut der nicht
entscheiden kann ob er harry potter ins
leserin oder guten durchschnitt sagen
unentschieden unentschieden ich glaube
nicht dass man ex das extra geld
ausgeben muss
als nächstes kommen herr und frau
chardonnay einmal sechs tänze von
entwickler der teure wein ist ein 2018
pascua raum wien der boni aus frankreich
mit 7 99 kann diese flasche auch dann
mal was leisten sie soll nicht nur fans
sie aussehen sondern auch gut schmecken
der günstige kandidat ist ein kandidat
der mir schon immer im supermarkt
aufgefallen ist weil ich finde dass es
einfach ein sehr schönes design es sieht
aber auch ein bisschen billig aus ich
mein' günstig muss ja nicht gleich
billig sein
aber der sieht wirklich meiner meinung
nach billig ausweislich sind wir bei
diesem chardonnay okay bei 3 eur 99 ist
auch nicht günstig er kommt aus
frankreich
wir haben unseren ersten korken ist aber
auch nicht so ein richtiger korken von
plastikkarten
ich kann mich nicht erinnern dass ich
schon mal chardonnay getrunken habe ich
weiß jetzt gar nicht also ich weiß
nichts über wein dass wir aber deswegen
ist meine meinung auch sehr ehrlich ich
bin ein normaler sucht ob er einfach nur
seine um fachkraft liche meinung zu
einem gibt es mal fangen wir mit dem
teuren an brust leute oha
dieser wein der wein riecht einfach nach
einem baguette und es ist nicht mal aus
frankreich nein es rief level i wie
frisch gebackenes brot oder baguette
das ist das kann man nie sein der wein
aus frankreich riecht einfach nach
bargeld dieser doch der geht ab sofort
in die nase
[Musik]
ja es schmeckt einfach noch ballett aber
sehr lecker ein sehr leckeres bei delta
marko marin für sieben euro 99 9
doch geht ja dagegen haben jetzt
natürlich unsere günstige variante die
gegen dieses bergerlebnis vielleicht
abpacken wird ruß leute ja das riecht
nicht agentur wirklich gut netz 3 okay
das ist wieder so
ich meine das hat wahrscheinlich
feineren aromen
aber ich muss sagen wenn ich für 300
eine literflasche kriege nämlich lieber
die weil nur weil das nach bargeld
schmeckt also jemand um mega witzig
finde ich will sagen der gelbe günstige
chardonnay hat gewonnen aber der ist
schon verdammt gut man muss schon sagen
wäre es verdammt gut wer sieht auch fans
sie aus das ist schon eine tolle flasche
und es schmeckt nach bargeld perfekt so
kommen wir zu unserem letzten kandidat
und den habe ich mit absicht nach hinten
geschoben
denn es ist grauer burgunder kauer
burgunder habe ich angefangen zu trinken
als ich nach berlin gekommen
da habe ich über jemanden das mal
probieren dachte york trauer gründer
schmeckt mir das wird in zukunft mein
wein sein ich hole immer dieses deutsche
weintor grauer burgunder und habe ja nie
mein mann ist erweitert wo ich jetzt
sagen muss chardonnay gefällt mir
richtig gut und ein bruder riesling dazu
sage ich auch nicht mehr nein aber was
mich jetzt viel mehr interessiert ist
ist es wichtig beim grauen burgunder
teuer oder günstig zu trinken ich habe
hier schon ein bisschen was weggetrunken
einzig midstream tag aber verlassen uns
nicht beirren
davon lassen wir uns nicht beirren wir
schauen uns mal dem teuren kandidaten an
und zwar heißt diese flasche drei
freunde und es klingt so als auch
irgendwie til schweiger mit matthias
schweighöfer in bayern gemacht hat
klingt auf jeden fall cool das design
ist schön und der preis ist sehr stolz
es ist der teuerste wein den wir heute
probieren für neun euro 99 kriegt man
eine 0,75 flasche und wir sagen der muss
viel besser schmecken als der günstige
grauer burgunder von schönaich trocken
2009/10 qualitätswein rheinhessen der
günstiger liegt bei drei euro 49 und das
war tatsächlich der günstigste den ich
gefunden habe
mögen die trinkspiele beginnen oder zu
ende gehen ich werde auf jeden fall
schon was von wein grauer burgunder mein
favourit mal schauen wer mich überzeugt
u
der teure hat auch viel mehr sprudeln
sieht man ganz viele kleine bläschen von
der farbe würde ich jetzt nicht sagen
das gibt sich nichts das sie gleich aus
also der teure riecht sehr mild bis nach
gebäck so eine klunder tasche
der günstige hat wieder diesen sauren
geruch wie probiert mal den günstigen
erkenne ich meinen grauen burgunder da
drin
ja das ist ein stabiler grauer burgunder
blumig dazu noch was dazu ein frischer
trockener weißwein mit ausgewogener
fruchten duft erinnert an birne und
anderen
das mit anklängen von nussigen aroma ja
ich weiß wo die anderen das riecht man
ganz toll so komisch alles kommt von der
weintraube und am ende das schmeckt nach
bargeld oder rift nach anderen posten
der letzte schluck also die sagen hier
nicht zum geschmack
leute der günstige hat definitiv
gewonnen
der schmeckt viel besser wow also mir
schmeckt der günstige besser ich habe
definitiv nicht das gefühl dass neun
euro 99 diesen wein rechtfertigen sei
und damit geht der punkt an die günstige
flasche leider konnte da habe ich kein
ausgleich geschaffen werden ich glaube
tatsächlich dass teure weine besser
schmecken beziehungsweise ein bisschen
hochwertiger schmecken außer jetzt bei
diesen drei freunde york erzählt mir
dieses weiter ist in echt irgendwie voll
spaß gemacht ich finde das voll
interessant so diese geschmäcker
herauszufinden und zu gucken
schmeckt der weihnacht baguette oder
schmeckt in das nach ananas aber
trotzdem sollte man es daran erinnern
alkohol nicht so ein bisschen als
ausrede grad zu verwenden bei quarantäne
ist und wir können ja alles machen
schaut trotzdem drauf wie ihr wann ihr
zu welcher gelegenheit ihr etwas trinkt
soll das wars mit mein video bis zum
nächsten mal
schreibt eure erfahrungen mit weißwein
seid ihr weiß weinkenner können wir ein
paar tipps geben wie man den besten wein
für sich findet schreibt gerne alles in
die kommentare und wir sehen uns beim
ich mal wieder tipps wie und bis wann
sonst hat sie sport machen wollte jeden
tag um 12 uhr fsc wanne kommt super das
zu einem wein testing video ohne job